Our scripture passage this morning comes from Matthew 28 verse 16.
Now the eleven disciples went to Galilee to the mountain to which Jesus had directed them.
And when they saw him, they worshiped him. But some doubted.
And Jesus came and said to them,
All authority in heaven and on earth has been given to me.
Go therefore and make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit.
Teaching them to observe all that I have commanded you.
And behold, I am with you always to the end of the age.
This is the word of the Lord.
Thank you, Lauren.
Well, about a mile and a half down the road from here at the foot of Lasseter Mountain
is a pear tree.
And when I was a little boy, I used to climb into that pear tree.
It was there in our driveway in our family home.
And I remember perching in my favorite spot on that pear tree and just letting my mind roam
and my imagination go wild.
And I remember just dreaming about what might be to come in the future.
And, you know, I never became a spy.
Like I thought I might be one day.
I never even became an NBA basketball star, sadly.
But I can honestly say that God did more than I could have ever have anticipated.
And one thing I'm not sure I did anticipate was to be right back where I was then
for it to come full circle.
And it is really surreal to be back here not only in Alabama, but in North Jefferson County
just down the road from Archer Road where that pear tree is.
And this morning we're looking at the end of the Gospel of Matthew.
And here in the book of Matthew, Jesus has come to the end of his earthly ministry.
And here at the very end of his earthly ministry, he brings his disciples right back to where they started.
Right back to where it all began.
He took them to Galilee.
And in many ways, this was a surprising place for Jesus to begin his ministry
and perhaps a surprising place for him to give what is now known as the Great Commission.
Because you see, the religious establishment was not from Galilee.
They were further south in Judea.
The Galileans were kind of their country cousins who lived further north.
A lot of them were fishermen and farmers by trade.
In fact, they were known for their country accents.
So if you were down in Judea and you wanted to tell a joke, you might put on a thick Galilean accent.
And also in Galilee, they were kind of country folk, but also their religion was practiced a little bit loosely, shall we say.
They identified as being Jews, but they were heavily influenced by the culture that was around them.
And they were known for that.
I wonder if any of that sounds familiar in terms of the context of where we are sat here this morning.
And yet, this is where Jesus chose to begin his earthly ministry.
This is where he chose his disciples from.
As far as we can tell, every single one of the 11 disciples gathered here were from Galilee.
By the way, a side note, the only one who wasn't was a man called Judas Iscariot.
And now the Galileans are all here together.
So why does he bring them back to Galilee?
Well, I have to say to the nostalgia I feel at the moment, it's not for nostalgia's sake.
There was some significance to the place itself and their shared stories there,
but more important is what these disciples witnessed there in Galilee.
Because it was there that they first saw Jesus.
It was there that they first heard the words, follow me.
So now in these final moments, he takes them back to where they witnessed those things
and they heard those words and he draws everything that they've seen over the past three years together
into a final statement about who he truly is and what it truly means to follow him.
So as we get started today, can I ask you a question?
Why are you here?
Not in Galilee, but in North Jefferson County in Mount Olive.
What drew you to this church plant?
I imagine there's probably lots of reasons.
It could be the maybe the pioneering nature of the thing is a draw for some folks
or maybe you've got friends or family who are here.
Maybe you've experienced disappointments in a church you've been at.
Maybe it's just closer to home where you actually live.
Maybe you're not sure why you're here, but you're testing the waters to see what this is all about.
Maybe, I don't know, you heard there's barbecue and you were hungry and you wanted to come here.
It's probably honestly a mix of a few things for all of us.
But whatever your reasons for coming, I want us to see that we are ultimately here for the very same reason
that Jesus gathered his disciples on that day.
So we're here for, let's say, four reasons from Matthew chapter 28.
First of all, we are here because number one, Jesus has all authority.
Everything in the passage and everything that would happen afterwards,
including us being sat here right here in this moment,
flows from what Jesus says in verse 18.
When he says, all authority in heaven and on earth has been given to me.
Afterwards, you'll see the little word therefore.
So everything that's going to happen is connected to his authority.
When Jesus comes to the disciples in the passage,
you may have noticed that he was met with a mixed response.
Some are worshiping him, but others of them are doubting.
Now remember, he's just been brutally murdered and now here he is.
He's risen from the dead.
Some are elated and they're all in with worship and others just cannot believe their eyes.
So it's hard to maybe interpret what it is that they are seeing in front of them.
So Jesus does the interpreting for them and he makes it absolutely clear this is who they are looking at.
He doesn't give them some parable now or cryptic statement.
He plainly tells them exactly who he is.
He's the one who possesses all authority.
He's the King who reigns over all things.
Now his kingly authority has been a theme that is stretched right the way throughout the gospel of Matthew.
So if you go back to the very first verse, you know, you got a genealogy given there,
but right from the beginning Jesus has introduced to us as the son of David.
Right?
So we see the connection with King David.
He was the promised offspring of King David who was to be given a kingdom that would last forever.
When the wise men came seeking Jesus, who did they come seeking?
They came seeking the one who is to be King.
When he preaches his first sermon, what is his message?
Repent for the kingdom of heaven is at hand.
His authority is then seen as he goes about his ministry.
His authority is seen as his teaching.
You hear him saying things like, you have heard it said, but I say unto you.
When he speaks, it's obvious that the truth that he is speaking isn't derivative of somewhere else.
He is the very source of truth itself in what he says.
And so when people hear him, they say he's speaking as someone who is speaking with authority,
not as our scribes.
His authority is also seen in his miracles.
He has power over the elements.
He calms the storms.
He has power to heal diseases.
He has power to cast out demons.
He has power to raise the dead.
Life itself was in his hands.
He even has the power to forgive sins.
The religious authorities of his day thought he was being blasphemous.
And they said, who can forgive sins but God alone?
How can he claim this for himself?
And so they opposed his authority.
And that opposition to his authority eventually led to his death.
And in his death, it's interesting that the thing that they mock is his kingly authority.
So what do they do?
When he's brought before the authorities, they put a robe on him.
And they put a crown on him, a crown of thorns on him.
They give him a reed as though it was a scepter.
And they kneel before him and they mockingly say, Hail, King of the Jews.
And they spit on him.
And they strike him with a scepter.
And they rip the robe from off his back.
He's then lifted up, but not on a throne, but on a cross.
And over the cross reads, What?
This is Jesus, King of the Jews.
And as he's up there, they hurl insults at him saying,
He saved others.
He cannot save himself.
Of course, he was able to save himself, but he chose not to.
Why?
Because he was there to save us.
He was there dying in the place of rebels, people who rebel against his authority so that we might be reconciled to God.
He was there dying in the place of sinners.
He was there in his authority accomplishing what he came to do.
Then his authority is finally seen when he rises from the dead.
He conquers the grave.
He rises in power.
The King has defeated sin.
He has defeated the powers of evil and he's defeated death itself.
And so now before his disciples, before us in his word,
he makes it clear this is who he is.
This is the extent of his authority.
All of it belongs to him, all authority in heaven and on earth.
Abraham Kuiper had it right when he said,
There is not a square inch in the whole domain of our human existence over which Christ, who is sovereign over all, does not cry mine.
His dominion extends over every place, every person and every part of our existence.
So how should we respond to him?
If he is over it all, we should open up the whole of our lives to him.
So that brings us to the second reason why we're here.
Or at least why we ought to be is because number two, Jesus calls us to follow him.
He calls us to follow him.
This great revelation of who Jesus is is followed by what is often called the Great Commission,
where he tells his disciples to go and make disciples of all nations.
We're going to get to that in a moment.
But before we see that we're called to participate in making disciples,
we are first recipients of those who responded to that call.
In other words, we're called to be disciples of Jesus.
So what does this actually mean?
Right? As these disciples are going out to then make other disciples,
and the message has come to us here today, well, what does it mean to then be a disciple of Jesus?
Does it mean, I don't know, every head bowed, every eye closed, no one looking around?
Does it mean like walk the aisle at the end of the service?
Does it mean repeat a prayer after someone?
Does it mean commit to only exclusively listen to Christian radio from here on out?
Like what does it mean to be a disciple of Jesus?
Well, a couple of things. We can say lots of things,
but a couple of things just grounded in what we see in the text itself here today.
One thing is it means receiving a new identity.
When you become a follower of Jesus, your life no longer belongs to yourself.
It belongs to him.
Right? He's in charge, not me.
It means letting go of our resistance to Jesus and instead receiving him as our King.
When you repent of your sin and you put your faith in Jesus,
you are united to him in his death and resurrection.
Your old life is gone and you've been given a new life in him.
You are now a follower of his. You belong to him.
Your life is bound with his.
And that union with Jesus is represented in baptism.
Right? So he tells his disciples here,
go make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
More about that in a second.
But just as a little caveat here, you might think it's oppressive to think like,
oh, I belong to someone. I belong to Jesus.
But remember, to belong to Jesus is more liberating than anything you will ever experience.
To belong to him is to be set free from sin and from the forces of evil
and to be empowered to live the life that you were made for.
To belong to Jesus isn't so much binding as it is liberating
because you belong to someone who cares for you far more than you could ever care for yourself.
One of the ways that belonging is communicated is through a family name.
I don't know if you've noticed, but over the years,
names seem to become a bit more individualized.
Has anybody else noticed that?
Maybe the older you are in here, the more you can see.
Years ago, decades ago, there was just a handful of names,
just kind of standard names that are given out.
And whereas now, I don't want to give examples
as to name somebody who sat here,
but everybody's given a very specific name.
And if you're given a traditional name,
it's got to have unique spelling that goes along with it.
So I feel sorry for those who are teachers.
I have to spell all these kids' names and remember all the names.
And by the way, I checked out the statistics last week
and I was like, is this just me?
No, actually, that has increased in recent generations
and there's probably reasons for that.
We won't get into it now.
But as those names have changed,
there's something else that hasn't changed much,
at least nowhere near at the same rate.
And that is people's last names,
the family names that they were born into.
In Numbers 6 and verse 27,
God has looked on His people and He says,
They are mine, they belong to me,
and I'm going to put my name on them.
Right? So they're His family.
And one of the ways that this would be communicated to His people
was by a blessing that would be spoken over them by Aaron.
His singular name,
the name that had been put on them
was going to be spoken over them three times.
I wonder if you know the verse.
Here's the blessing.
The Lord bless you and keep you.
The Lord, there's the name again,
make His face to shine upon you
and be gracious to you.
The Lord lift up His countenance upon you
and give you peace.
The Lord, the Lord, the Lord.
Today, through faith in Jesus,
we are brought into the family of God,
into the loving relationship of the Father, Son, and Spirit.
You might say we are brought into,
I've got to say it, Trinity Fellowship.
And when we're brought into that relationship with God
through faith in Jesus,
He puts His name on us.
He speaks His name over us.
And where is God's name spoken over His people today?
Where do we hear that communicated?
Well, here we see it,
baptizing them in the singular name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit.
So baptism shows us that we are identified,
we have identified with the Lord in His death
and in His resurrection,
but it's also a naming ceremony,
like the threefold blessing,
spoken by Aaron over God's people.
We're baptized in the name of the Father, Son, and Spirit.
But what's happening there?
When we're trusting in Christ,
when we are united to Him,
God is saying,
you belong to me, your mind.
We've been given a new identity as a follower of Jesus.
Secondly, we're given a new way of life.
It's about a new way of life.
The reality of the new life
that we're given through Jesus
is lived out as we walk in step with Jesus.
You see here that disciples are told to do what?
To observe all that He has commanded them.
And by the way, notice it doesn't say,
teaching them all that I have commanded you.
I don't know about you,
but I've heard this passage before taught in this way.
But it doesn't say,
teach them all that I've commanded you.
It says, teach them to what?
To observe all that I have commanded you.
Well, of course, you've got to be taught it to observe it.
But the thing that's being taught here
is that way of life, the practice,
this obedience that we are being called to.
So, disciples are not those
who merely know the way of Jesus.
Disciples are those who follow the way of Jesus.
The way we can see that we belong to Him,
that we really have been united to Christ by faith,
is in our walk with Him.
So, let's not make the mistake of equating
the quantity of knowledge we have
with the quality of our discipleship.
And I think particularly in the Western world,
in like North America, in places in Europe,
we're quick to do that.
I think discipleship equals the amount that I know
rather than the life that has been changed.
In the early 20th century,
there was a Swiss theologian
who was considered by many to be
the greatest Christian intellectual
of the 20th century.
He was published over 600 times his works.
His longest work was over 9,000 pages long,
stretching across 13 volumes.
But one of his last works to be published
long after he died
was his decades-long correspondence
with his mistress.
But on the flip side,
you know, there's often a village in Senegal.
There's a grandmother who's there.
She's never learned to read.
She's never had the opportunity to learn how to read.
But she knows Jesus.
She loves him.
And she's eager to gather with the people of God
every single week.
And she goes hungry.
And she listens to the Word of God.
And she is being transformed into the likeness of Jesus.
She's growing in love for him
and growing in love for her neighbor.
Let me ask you,
which one is following Jesus?
The one who knows just about everything there is to know
or the one who is following what he's given them.
Don't mishear me.
I hope we swim in some deep theological waters
here at Trinity Fellowship.
For sure.
I mean, our first series is starting next week.
It's on the Book of Ephesians.
So get ready.
But let's pray that the depths of our theology
is matched by the depths of our discipleship.
Now, this doesn't mean we're going to follow Jesus perfectly.
We will fail time and time again.
By the way, if it's any encouragement,
his original crew didn't follow him perfectly either.
Remember what they're doing here.
Some of them are worshiping and others are doubting.
Right?
They're there with their doubts, their fears.
This word for doubt is only used one other time in Matthew.
And it's when Peter sank.
Do you remember he was walking on the water with Jesus?
And then he starts to look at the wind and the waves around him
and he begins to sink.
He says, Jesus saved me and Jesus draws him out of the water
and he says, oh, you of little faith, why did you doubt?
So there was a mingling there of like Peter had the faith
to step out onto the water.
He's looking to Jesus.
He's been saved by Jesus.
But there's still room to grow.
And that's the case for all of us here.
As we follow Jesus, we will do so with imperfect faith.
But we can do so knowing that he will be with us
and will draw us back to himself time and time again.
Our imperfect faith is in a perfect Savior.
Third reason why we're here.
We're here because Jesus sends us to make disciples.
So the central imperative or command in verses 18 and 19
is make disciples.
In the other words around it show how that's done
by going, baptizing and teaching.
And Jesus here, you can see,
he doesn't give like a detailed list of instructions.
One of the reasons that they are putting,
he doesn't give a list of detailed instructions
is that they're gonna put into practice
what they've already seen in practice
over the past three years with him.
They are now to do what they have seen,
they have received, and now they are to give
out of what they have received.
So they're to make disciples
as they have been made disciples.
So you might wonder, does this apply to us?
Or is this just for the 11?
Well if they are to teach the disciples to observe
everything that they have been commanded,
well what was the final command?
Go make disciples, all right?
So those who are made disciples are then called
to go and make disciples of others.
And that baton has been passed through the generations
and has now come to us.
Another way of saying this is to say
that Trinity Fellowship does not exist
merely for itself.
Not to be gross, but ingrown things
can be pretty nasty.
And they can be hurtful.
Let's not be an ingrown church.
We exist not just for ourselves,
but to go and to make disciples locally
and globally to make Christ known
to others in word or in deed.
So disciples are called to be disciple makers
and that includes us.
And you know what?
Church planting is a wonderful opportunity
for a fostering disciple making.
I love established churches
and I hope one day we will be an established church.
But you know at an established church
it can be easy to slip into the habit
of just turning up and receiving
in a way that's different to planting.
At a church plant, you know, it's all hands on deck.
I mean you brought your own chair this morning,
a lot of you so well done.
Maybe you're here and you've gotten used to
dropping off your kids at kids ministry every week.
But now perhaps you're going to experience
what it is like to serve in children's ministry as well.
Maybe you've been involved in home groups before
and it's been wonderful to attend a home group
in the past and pretty soon you might very well
be leading a home group.
You know the list could go on.
There's opportunities for disciple making.
I also want to say this that those activities
aren't necessarily the same as disciple making.
They can be an essential part
but let's not miss the point.
Activity and business isn't the same as being there
to see disciples made of Jesus.
And so the command to go here implies
that we're not going to sit around here
waiting for people to come to us.
The trajectory is outward.
We're called to go to others.
Where they are.
And also the command to baptize
means that we are going to be engaging with people
who previously did not know the Lord.
And then as we've seen here
we're going to help them God willing to grow as disciples.
Can I just say that one of the fears that I have
about planting in Alabama in Jefferson County
is that we're going to be a church
that just shuffles the deck one more time.
In other words like getting just a few more Christians
from other churches and we're just going to swap around
and actually miss the opportunity
to find those who do not yet know Jesus
and make him known to them.
You know I'm very much open to welcoming folks
from other churches.
Don't get me wrong.
And I especially if someone's in a place
where they're not hearing all that Jesus commanded them
for sure but let's not forget the Son of Man
came to seek and to save the lost.
He left the 90 and 9 and went after the one that was lost.
That applies not only here but also around the world.
From day one let's determine that we will be a church
that is passionate about God's global mission.
You know the gospel, praise God,
has made its way around the world
since this command was originally given.
But here's where things are at up to like today.
2024 today there are over 3 billion people
who are living in either a people group or a place
where there's little to no access to the gospel.
In other words they're not just surrounded by people
who have never heard.
They're in a people group or a place that has never heard
and there's no church that is there
seeking to make Christ known to them.
That's why we're here to make Christ known
from North Jefferson to the ends of the earth.
For some it may be going to one of those places
and for others it may be sending and supporting those who go.
But I pray that we would be a church that would participate
in what God is doing around the world.
Imagine being one of those 11 disciples there that day.
I mean it is almost laughable to think
that they were given such an impossible task.
I mean to say that these Galileans of all people
didn't feel prepared for this task ahead of them
would be an understatement.
They must have felt so inadequate.
Us? All nations? Really?
I don't know how you felt in the weeks leading up to this week
but the past few days has been a mix of
I must say worship and doubt in my own soul.
It's easy to start looking forward to
everything the Lord is going to do
but also start to look at the wind and the waves
and the logistics of everything that needs to happen
in the coming days and weeks.
Am I the only one who feels that way
or are there other people who feel that too?
So let's hear the final reason why we're here
fourthly and lasty.
We're here because Jesus has promised to always be with us.
We're here because Jesus is here.
He's brought us here.
He is at work.
He is building his church.
You see after giving them this seemingly impossible task
he says, and I think I missed this
up until like a couple of days ago
he said to them,
behold,
lest their eyes start to wonder
having heard this impossible task.
He says, okay, hey, right here,
behold, disciples.
Well, what do they need to pay careful attention to
as their eyes are beginning to wonder?
Perhaps the doubts are arising.
The fears are there.
What do they need to see?
I am with you always,
even to the end of the age.
I don't know if any of you are fans of C.S. Lewis.
I'm a big fan of his movies.
They're great.
I've read a book or two, I think.
But Prince Caspian, I've not read the book,
but there's a great film adaptation of that.
And my favorite scene probably in the movie
is where you've got the Narnians on one side,
and then you've got their enemies on the other side
of this river.
And they are far outnumbered by their enemies,
and they are about to be demolished.
And there's this little bridge in between the rivers
and between the river and these two armies.
And then Lucy, little Lucy, this little girl,
steps onto the bridge,
and she stares down the army in front of her,
and she pulls out her little dagger
like, I dare you to walk across my bridge.
And you're thinking, well, where in the world
has she got this kind of courage from?
What is she thinking?
What happens?
Aslan, the lion who reigns over all of Narnia,
steps out from behind her.
He lets out his roar, and the army is defeated.
So her confidence to move forward
didn't come from herself or her own strength.
It came from knowing who was with her.
That's been the history of God's people.
As God led his people through the wilderness,
his presence that went with them.
Moses said, Lord, if your presence doesn't go with this,
I don't want to go.
He said, my presence will be with you.
And then when he led his people into the Promised Lands,
he spoke to Joshua.
Joshua was no doubt fearful.
What did he say to Joshua?
He said, just as I was with Moses,
so I will be with you, I will not leave you
for sake you be strong and courageous.
And here, at the end,
he promises to always be with us
even through the end of the age.
And he is here with us now.
We can't possibly know everything that lies ahead of us,
but we can know who is going to be with us.
Jesus has promised to be with us always,
and we can move forward knowing that he will never leave us
or forsake us, and he's enough.
So let's follow him. Let's pray together.
Lord, we thank you that you,
the one with all authority,
has promised to be with us always.
Lord, you are here with us now.
Lord, I pray that you would help us
to hear your call to follow.
And the Lord, we would step out,
knowing that you are enough.
Lord, draw us to you now.
Grant that we would see more of you.
We would follow you.
And Lord, that you would do exceedingly, abundantly above,
all that we could ask or even think in the days ahead.
If we ask this in your mighty name, amen.